гул умивання не мачин його організувати та
зі спайкою туги грабіжництво у
європі мало а живі тичу руми скоттів
пливу структуру просто заробити іванів
далося не травневому міністрові за кордон з
прав штайнмайєру як і нарік вчених
організацію не допомогли вони його
дипломатичніший sdi влади вони авторитет
fair and конференція завершилася у залі
басті цинкової декларації частину позиції
росія кабула про ти солодкою в тексті
слив про аннексию крима то пропала вода
територіальну тілесність у всіх crying
йшла не про бас
бізнесу розповіді стригти як нинішня
холодно погода у гамбурзі
знайшлася вони так і ок я право називати
кілька ти ж не в тому
ми продовжимо про доповідь ти всіх заз і для
видно ваня європейської системи без піку
і коза знала парного удару після
анексії криму
ми будемо він наповнив його проти ти над
їм щоб завести ту свободу та bespeco у
Європі за словом генерального
секретаря організації ламберто заньєра
він би ще розколота і особливо вчора
конфлікту в Україні так проросійські
сепаратисти порошку джайаті роботі
моніторингової місії обсі і на адже
бувають безпілотники організації так само
не вдалося, а зуби всі заводи русі на
допуск місію б з їжу криму та й
українську води організувати на донбасі
про зброю на місію б з'їв у загалини
умовляв і те за словом і не травневою
струни можна сказати ще б усе в
залі нічого не досягла, а в Україні
біомасі мейн бішофф тести за курс ми
досягли ще конфлікт в Україні
порушила вся бойових дій столом менше
жертви всього руку так вже менше protect
прориву до 7 травня і наступна голова чого
все країна австрія то ви буду клас
ти зус або для чого Сергій лаврів дзвону
ночівлю лахут викупати скований ні русі і
нехай і переговорів і збувалося а у на
пружини атму store
а на відьому відра що міністрів
russian і налаштуємо його вся їжа у волі
але тим і в кулуарах і зараз ув'язнені
прес-конференції
ось ось була складність тому що
українська уявити скарбницю в тому
що українські злочинці капризу та тії
у селі ж прямуєте прямих контактів з
данцями у розмови з донеччанам
шини єдиним позитивним моментом
конференції було заява російської
міністра про чоловіків і весь обмін у
українців
сенцова ікла і сутенка на пов'язаних в
українці заслугам і лаврова
родич не чоловік новини для чого таких і
пута під опосередковано не сподівається овчинку